flesh fake skin why are he and she so
upset and this guy's totally chill no no
no you know your life is different now
I am vlogging now I'm using my iPhone
right now because I left my vlogging
camera at the studio in which we shoot
this might get episodes which maybe is a
good segue how's my impression of the
worst human ever
oh here's the clamor of this might get
writing room says where all the genius
ideas are born bred and the word
marinate and this couch is so gross to
me oh we recording yeah recording it's
Wednesday and I am dressed like I walk
straight out of babyGap you I just
uploaded my vlog encompassed the first
like week and a half of shooting this
might get and you guys are really liking
it which makes me happy and excited to
continue this this vlogging thing that's
going on I turned on my camera for a
reason and I got distracted by my own
juvenile fashion set and damn it was it
I'm talking about I'm a great vlogger in
that vlog I talked about how I got a PR
package from 7-eleven and that I only
get PR packages from 7-eleven and
poopourri I guess what literally showed
up today
I got damn package from poo pourri
that's right for International Women's
Day look at this they're too sweet a
card with my name on it they know how to
spell my name and to more sense of poo
pourri I might be crossing into the
territory of like total [ __ ] creep
with the amount of poo pourri I have
throughout my house this is original
citrus scent they also give me this
frame that's like magnetic lucite frame
the world needs more badass babes like
you go Barry stop flirting we're already
in a relationship you keep flirting with
me but I also like you don't have to
stop I'm sorry I had to turn the camera
back on because I just thought of this
great
joke after I turned it off poo pourri
they really know the way to a girl's
chart alright I'm done okay haha what
look Wow found out Jared sleeper DEET
wanna get it check it out just by
looking at me I'm sure you assume it is
bright and early on a Thursday morning
you can see that clock right yeah it's
2:30 p.m. hey and it's Thursday I
dropped off at the airport this morning
as he's doing shows in Dallas in it I'm
don't know where's the microphone on
this I should know by now I dropped them
off at the airport this morning he's
doing shows in Dallas this weekend I'm
gonna jump down to Dallas this weekend
to hang out for a day or two before that
I'm gonna look like a ripoff Terry
Richardson cosplay / and I got my blue
apron delivery there's no ad here like a
subscription mailbox thing they
sponsored my podcast not too deep if you
don't listen to it she listened to it
where did why so I'm gonna make some
lunch I thought I just film it because
now that I've decided to start vlogging
I have an internal endless anxiety but
I'm not remembering to film enough
content each week to live up to
expectations of making a full blog view
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my blog look I'm remembering the blog
and I am remembering the most flattering
of angles I'm going to pick up some
items that sounds like the shadiest
thing of all time I'm a marine I've been
talking about wanting to get the crew
and everyone that's working on our new
show something just to show like our
appreciation for how hard they're
working this first like a couple weeks
when we're trying to figure out how
everything works and our groove and what
the show is and so I kind of did a
spontaneous impulsive Amazon order last
night for everyone and I want to give it
to them tomorrow because we're shooting
tomorrow it's Friday I don't want to
wait till next week because I'm just
impatient so I'm going to the Amazon
facility right now to pick up all the
things that I ordered at 7:20 p.m. let's
see if they have it
[Music]
okay that was bonkers I don't know if
and you have experience with this but I
like I said ordered this stuff of Amazon
and then I went to pick it up at a
facility so I could get it quicker than
they could deliver which have never done
before and the facility that I picked it
up on was USC which is a University of
Southern California to college it said
pick up your packages the USC village
which I didn't think about at all and
it's like I literally just picked up my
Amazon package is plural there's
something like these [ __ ] from an
Amazon store in the middle of the USC's
campus for those of you that don't know
me I went to a very tiny liberal arts
college in northern New Jersey and I've
always had this like lingering
bitterness that I didn't do college
right that didn't go to party school or
a big school or a cool school or I just
didn't like enjoy it the way that most
people should enjoy it and holy [ __ ]
getting into that USC village made me
feel like ah this is like what college
is supposed to be
32 now just stepping onto this grounds
to pick up my seven neck massager I had
this very quick wave of depression oh
man I just got a quick reminder of like
this is what college is like don't feel
bummed that I missed out on like a
college experience but then I was
leaving the parking garage and I was
trying to get my like parking garage
ticket to work and some kids I was
coming into the parking garage that
looked super cool and definitely was a
college student he just leaned out his
window to me and said hey I like your
aesthetic so I'm validated they are
wrapped oh good morning
there we go perfect hi don't mind me
just casually going to work with so many
presents in trash bags
it is 7:40 a.m. and I am on my way to
the office mamrie said already we're
getting ready because written link I
don't think I've mentioned this written
link or shooting with us today we're
just so exciting we love those guys
they're so awesome and we really wanted
to shoot an episode with them
in the beginning stages of this show
because we knew there's gonna be a lot
of like direct comparisons to good
mythical morning it's two friends
hanging out in the early part of the day
talking about silly nonsensical things
so obviously it's gonna be compared and
we wanted to make sure that people knew
that this was not a ripoff of good
mythical morning which love good
mythical morning we say Shing on this
show
it's bleeped albeit back they don't come
in the morning but the fun thing is
we're doing like a best friend off game
where we're seeing how much maybe now I
know about them and how much they know
about us and we're surprising it because
we're going to get dressed up like them
they don't know so let's see if we can
get this surprise to work also the other
surprises I have 7 neck massages in my
car right now
what a Friday and then I'm supposed to
go to Dallas Texas after this what's
happening good morning Freddie
we're getting ready for written link
watching this war planning right now
breakfast of champions on set to me I'm
just capturing beautiful beautiful rare
animals in the wild I'm trying to get
ready you're trying to get read okay we
are behind the scene getting dressed is
written like a very serious discussion
about which plaid is too much but also
written link showed up like cool cool he
showed up like they got makeovers like
an hour before they got here so now
we're like kind of second-guessing our
street cosplayer but still we're
committing babies are coming link but
she also kind of ground away a little
bit like hipster Betty Boop right link
came in looking cool and he threw our
whole plan transformation is happening
surely might get the idea the idea may
be trying to figure out her link
character yeah that's really good these
are runway walks you guys gone go and
sit down or spread
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I landed in Dallas a couple hours
ago Brooks is doing comedy shows at a
comedy club called penis so funny and so
it's a walking distance I'm going over
there but I'm in Chuck E Cheese parking
lot right now it's like 10:30 at night
and I feel like a king creep ass pervert
the cool thing about vlogging twofold
one making content - if I get kidnapped
it's documented fine let's go watch haha
at hyena's okay so in Dallas we made a
pit stop though at Party City do under
it in the car no a spot check stop it
supposed to be cool
[Music]
we're bailing on it checks that
drugs didn't want it he's a fickle boy
today over Jimmy Jones he's finally
trying to go get stung before a show and
there's like nobody in there wait he got
in huh he got a sandwich can't wait
gotta eat now I deserve it this morning
brick slept for a couple of hours I
couldn't fall back asleep and then we
decided we've earned this I have to do
my job I'm working right now
oh hi those noises mean it's the morning
it is Tuesday morning in fact and we are
headed to that this might get set to
shoot six episodes this Sambia some big
long day I have 10,000 items with me
there's a lot of really fun episodes
planned to shoot today one in which
sorry Beyonce one in which we have a
Bitcoin expert just basically a smart
person coming in to teach us a Bitcoin
us I've been taught a Bitcoin is I think
like the 17 different times by various
intelligent humans and I've never
attained any of the information nor have
understood it in any regard so
let's go that's good do in 18th time
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
an invisible yeah
Reiko means is it being the total queen
Oh your lunch the lunch of a queen oh my
gosh
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
raisi [ __ ] good morning everyone over
common standing she is theirs Wednesday
morning and I am headed to shoot a
couple episodes of none too deep we shot
six episodes of this might get yesterday
and this might get tired because I can't
say I didn't sleep at all last night but
I can say I only slept for an hour last
night because I am uh you know when your
body gets in one of those modes and
you've drank coffee too late and you're
just like afraid of a potential like
boogeyman breaking into your house all
night so you don't fall asleep
yeah those minutes oh hey and now we are
going to record episodes not too deep
with Kelsey and Kate from BuzzFeed they
also have their own podcast on BuzzFeed
called adults [ __ ] that I was on a few
weeks ago and it's [ __ ] awesome these
girls Qing rule they're so cool so
that's why I'm slightly okay being
completely sleep-deprived today because
I know these girls are gonna be so fun
to talk to you and then we're talking to
the one and only mamrie Hart so let's
head over to not too deep I'm already
I'm like 20 minutes late install Patrick
upgrade ever which is very good news
because I'm very bad at all of those
things so go to space dock thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this if you like these sort of
like I'm not Friday's but if you like
these like wrap-ups or these week well
and link blogs let me know in the
comments down below and click that boat
on vacation because I want to say I
upload every Tuesday and Thursday but
you know that's interpretive so I don't
know
oh you crazy
[Laughter]